Chúng ta sẽ không có trang tìm, thì có khoảng khoảng 2 người là 1 trang thôi
Chúng ta đã bán của bây giờ mà dạ
À không?
Chúng ta đã nói là khoảng 2 người thì được trang xung đến nha rồi đến xíu thịt rồi
Đi ở đây nó sẽ là khoảng 2 người của nó để nè
Qua được là ai từ khoảng 1 trang thì khoảng 2 người là 1 trang
Đi ở đây nó sẽ có trang tìm tà tính tổng cộng 1, bí từ trang xung đến nha
Với lệ xíu thịt, cái này là hay lũ này như này
Trang xung, rất là nó vay mối khoảng 2 người nó khám hỏe khoảng 2 người nó rất là ăn đi
Em có gì thì được rồi?
Chúng mình được rồi nè, trang xung ở đây xong lại vui nha
Trang xung về nha để bú thông man rồi nha
Sau mà đến xíu thịt nó sẽ là đến tình tham trong man nữa
Bánh hiểu cái gì chuyện ở đâu?
Thưa bú thông về không?
Thông ở đi tạm trong cái thì có cảnh của nó này là bú thông
Bú nưởng giữa tạm trong cái tổng cộng 1 người nó sẽ bánh giống
1 người 2 cho mình
Hãy sẽ bánh giữa đủ mạng đâu
Hứy ở đoàn nhạc?
Bú tình nó nó là thang hiểu
Với trang, cái nhà
Nào, vô lơ nổ thịt chuyện thì thì xíu thịt chuyện
Tức ra khi máy lòng ở đâu thì chuyện này em rất là đừng tạm
Khi máy lòng ở đâu thì chuyện này không còn quan tâm là nó nghĩ gì nào?
Em chỉ có tâm được đâu thì quý đời
Em đâu là gì?
Lại xíu thịt nó nó thì quý đại chương
Với trang, cái gì đó?
Trang, sao?
Là vì chỉ tôi đủ 1 bú trang
Trên phía 1 bú trang, trang
Chỉ tôi ăn ngốc thì chuyện của chúng ta ăn trong những
Lấy trang, trang, chỉ bú trang luôn
Và đủ đều đau thì tôi đủ những quý
Bú trang
Nè, các bạn có mình là đi
Chở lại quá
Trang lấu kinh của thịt thành định dẫn thêm các bạn bởi bài trang hình vậy